as video games move closer into virtual
reality gamers are left wondering how
those first few VR titles are going to
play with Lucky's tale you know exactly
what you're getting an adorable 3d
platformer and you'll get it for free
when you pick up an oculus rift Lucky's
tale is built for virtual reality by
developer playful the studio started by
words with friends co-creator Paul
boettner with a bunch of cartoony
creatures and environments it appears to
have the same level of fun and charm as
its appstore cousin both betnar and
oculus rift creator Palmer Luckey are
excited for the little foxes adventure
Lucky's tale isn't the only game packed
in with the device if you preorder an
oculus rift before its launch in the
first quarter of 2016 you'll also get a
free copy of eval curry from ccp each
headset also includes an Xbox one
controller and the whole setup is going
to cost you an unannounced amount over
three hundred and fifty dollars we're
about to enter a brave new world with
the oculus rift and virtual reality the
more we learn about it the more you can
read about it on gamespot com